there are very few people have actually
in this industry you could work for a
big pharmaceutical industry for 20 years
and may not actually get to see a drug
and in its final stages or come to
market and that's very very common so
because it you know of all the drugs
that we develop all all the drugs that
come off the pipeline very very few make
it out
so the successes that you see are very
very few you know they're just few
candidates that have made it from a
thousand that started the journey and it
takes sometimes up to 15 years so you
for most cases you'd always have to
start with a project you know 50 years
prior and see it come to fruition you
know so and very few people do that so
but you tend to see this drug in
different stages and I have been
involved with several candidates and the
different stages of the development
process the candidate or drug candidate
that I we're now working with now is in
its final stage and it's exciting
because not very many people have
actually been able to be a part of a
team that would say they've seen the
last stage you know this is the filing
stage we've submitted you know new drug
application to the FDA so it's the final
stage and we're you know being you know
and not very many people can say they've
actually seen that so for me it's
exciting and it's a huge achievement